wir stehen vor allem der härtesten
winter in den vergangenen jahrzehnten
roberta welt hat selber eingeräumt jede
kilowattstunde zählt und das kann man
nur unterstützen allerdings
unterscheidet sich diese aussage vom
handeln der ampel koalition denn mitten
in diesem herbst und vor dem härtesten
winter seit vielen vielen jahren möchte
die ampelkoalition die kernkraftwerke in
deutschland abschalten das ist
unverantwortlich und wird dazu führen
dass die strom- und energiepreise weiter
steigen
daher mein plädoyer der hwk scholz
stoppen sie diesen hörsinn verlängern
sie die laufzeiten der kernkraftwerke
habe das kann es sein dass das schon
längst geplant ist eigentlich innerhalb
der partei jetzt einfach noch die wahl
in niedersachsen abgewandt und sie
wissen ja auch mit meiner situation
jetzt partei kann es sein das ist
eigentlich das ist eine sehr gute frage
und es gibt tatsächlich auch im berliner
regierungsviertel bei vielen
mittlerweile die vermutung dass die
grünen die niedersachsen war noch
abwarten wollen weil die grüne basis ja
gegen die verlängerung der laufzeiten
der kernkraftwerke ist das halte ich
wirklich für unverantwortlich weil wir
brauchen jetzt die entscheidung wir
brauchen jetzt planungssicherheit das
würde dazu führen dass die strompreise
erst einmal sinken würden weil einfach
das angebot wieder vergrößert werden
würde und deswegen kann man die
niedersachsen waren nicht abwarten wenn
herr habe so denkt dann macht er das
gegenteil dessen was er immer im
wahlkampf versprochen hat klar dass das
ein grund warum vielleicht auch menschen
das vertrauen in die politik verlieren
ich muss sagen ich als bürgerin sind da
schon sehr bedenklich naja ich glaube
ich auch aber man kann das argument ja
auch einmal umdrehen was bleibt von den
grünen denn wenn sie waffen liefern und
atomkraft
weiter laufen lassen sozusagen wenig und
jeder sprache das ist ja
ein
bisschen polemisch aber ja ich meine das
hauptsächlich aus ganz ernst war
eigentlich für politiker der moment wo
man sagt jetzt bin ich so weit von dem
weg dessen wegen ich bevor ich in einer
regierung kam politik gemacht habe das
jetzt auch mal schluss ist und das
glaube ich macht ist habe ich so schwer
und den grünen so schwer auch das letzte
gründungsmythos teilchen nämlich die
kernkraft oder die gegnerschaft zur
kernkraft aus der hand zu geben in der
sache selber finde ich ja das
hauptargument das hilft zu wenig
deswegen mache ich es ganz weg völlig
skurril zu machen sagt jede habe ich
jede aber es ist also erstens ist dass
der widerspruch in sich und dann muss
man sich einmal vorstellen ist wieder so
ein typischer politiker kopf geschwurbel
tings denn wenn ich jetzt sagen wir mal
drei kinder habe und habe aber nur
vereins was zu essen dann lasse ich ja
das essen nicht weg und würde somit alle
toten also ich meine es ist eine völlig
skurrile logik sondern man wird ja dann
versuchen das so aufzuteilen in meinem
beispiel oder wenigstens 1
durchzubringen also wird nutzt wird das
wenige was man hat er sonst könnte man
sagen das beispiel deswegen leben und
tod ein bisschen übertrieben ich finde
aber dass wir in einer phase sind wo wie
viele themen haben die am ende des tages
was vielleicht nicht mit 10 mio aber
mein arm und reich zu sehen millionen
haushalte können wir darum versorgt
werden wenn dies aber daraus nummern ich
glaube dass man den bürgern nur schwer
erklären kann aber was ja jeder weiß der
diesen berliner politikbetrieb
kennengelernt hat und wir sitzen ja drei
am tisch
politiker in parteien ticken anders habe
ich weiß ganz genau die niedersachsen
war es entscheidend für das überleben
seiner partei wird es kurzfristig und
deswegen ist völlig irrelevant was ein
bürger denkt was die wirtschaft denkt es
ist nur wichtig was die partei denkt das
ist für normalen menschen der sich für
parteien nur bedingt interessiert weil
ja nur ein bis zwei prozent der
deutschen überhaupt irgendwie einer
partei organisiert sind völlig undenkbar
und deswegen glaube ich haben viele
bürger ein riesenproblem überhaupt zu
verstehen wie dieses politikers
funktion aber da würde ich sagen jetzt
sind wir doch wirklich in der zeit wo
mit diesem tabu schluss sein muss da
habe ich ja noch ungewissen quasi
futuristischen respekt vor dem mit dass
das so ist wenn man wenn es wurscht ist
ob ich im oktober entscheiden oder
nächsten april jetzt geht es aber darum
dass die leute für armen das sozusagen
die leute frieren
doch mal endlich sagen und wir machen
das jetzt so egal er hat mir die 90er
jahre wo fast 80 prozent der leute ihren
arbeitsplatz wechseln mussten weil das
alles weg gefallen ist wir haben die
deindustrialisierung erlebt und in
meinem also auf jeden fall der punkt an
der sache ist es gab sehr viel während
in ostdeutschland erlebt na klar da
kommt mir aus sachsen ja also es gab
sehr viele suizide
es gab sehr viele menschen die in einem
fleck marke gefallen sind oder in eine
untiefe stache gefallen sind es gab
verdrängungswettbewerb bei den
arbeitsplätzen dieser neu entstanden
sind die männer haben sie bekommen damit
sie nicht unruhen veranstalten die
frauen guckten in die röhre also wir
haben sehr viele erfahrungen gesammelt
was es für eine bevölkerung bedeutet
wenn in einem industrieland eine
deindustrialisierung stattfindet egal
wie aus welche ursachen und deswegen
glaube ich dass wir gut beraten sind
sehr schnell neue sicherheit und die
bevölkerung reinzubringen und auch nach
außen auszustrahlen wir brauchen die
ausländischen investoren gerade wenn man
viel vor hat ich habe sorge dass die
energiewende sowie sie vielleicht mal
funktionieren könnte wenn man den in
allen bereichen eine gewisse
technologische tiefe erreichen würde
speicherung batterie ist und beispiel
dass es eine gute sache sein könnte und
dass die mehrheit der bevölkerung das
eigentlich auch will aber sie will es
nicht um den preis der eigenen existenz
und wenn man jetzt als partei nicht die
größe hat oder als regierung und sagt
die realitäten haben sich total geändert
wir stehen vor völlig neuen realitäten
unser parteiprogramm ist keine bibel
sondern wir sind in der lage die neuen
realitäten anzuerkennen und wir wenden
das jetzt und wir machen das anders aber
wir uns schon wir wollen ja auch schon
dass die bürger unzufrieden sind auch
angst haben als in thüringen zum
beispiel frau bieten kriegen jetzt schon
linke und fdp dann zusammen 49 macht
auch bei mir halt macht ihnen das angst
also wenn man die umfragen sieht ja ich
glaube was was viele politiker in berlin
und auch in anderen landesregierungen in
den bundesländer unterschätzen ist dass
der prozess einer radikalisierung der
ränder noch lange nicht abgeschlossen
ist und so wie die die fundis bei den
grünen radikal und zum teil
extremistischen sind ist bei der afg ja
auch und diese länder berühren sich und
leute die sehen dass sie in den
begebenheiten solide die affen
gleichsetzten
ich sage das ist es ja politische
theorie dass die extremen enden sich
immer irgendwann berühren und dass
menschen die das gefühl haben sie finden
in der mitte nicht mehr statt weil die
lebenswelten politiker von ihrer eigenen
einfach so wahnsinnig weit entfernt ist
die sind bereit sich zu radikalisieren
das kann man genau und auch an der
sprache von politikern über jahre sehr
klar erkennen das ist keine theorie ist
das ist gängige praxis und deswegen ich
glaube der der weimarer vergleich ist
zwar auf eine weise ausgelutscht und die
leute wollen ihn nicht mehr hören aber
genau das ist eine derartige
radikalisierung und eine wiederholung
der geschichte egal zu welcher radikalen
figur hin immer wieder möglich und das
wird meiner ansicht nach von den grossen
parteien völlig überschätzt und ich kann
mich haben sie angst vorm versagen ihrer
experten ich bin ich bin kein nein ich
bin kein ängstlicher mensch weil ich
glaube dennoch gibt es zeit etwas zu tun
aber dafür müssten sich mal links und
rechts der demokratischen mitte
außerhalb der länder müssten sich
gruppen müssten sich parteien müssten
sich
persönlichkeiten vor allen dingen finden
die sagen ist schluss wir reden klartext
weil das was herr h weg gemacht hat den
bäckern zu erklären dass sie nur keine
brötchen backen müssen und trotzdem
nicht pleitegehen das ist ja so
erkennbar bull städtereisen motivation
habe einmal sogar
da bin ich schon gut versteht nicht
glauben was bei einigen brauchen sind
leute aus dem realen leben aus der
wirtschaft ja wir haben eine
bundesregierung und die letzte für die
letzte gilt das glaube ich auch dass man
weniger und zwar jetzt und
händlersuche sie ein minister der mal
jemand in der wirtschaft gearbeitet
hatte ich rede nicht nur unternehmer
daher von den wahrscheinlich keiner
jemals in der fabrikhalle gestanden und
das ist genau diese art von politik
sehen wir aber eben nicht erst jetzt
sondern
alle werden mich erkannt das stimmt in
der tat also zum beispiel ist die frage
mit dem upload das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium sagt na gut
wenn es jetzt nicht produzieren wollen
weil ihnen die energiekosten so hoch
sind dann lassen sie salz und sie können
ja die hilfe in anspruch nehmen so
mergen werde aber nicht vor schuldner
sachsen anhalt und ansonsten können die
produktion der stilllegung dann gehen
halt ihre mitarbeiter in
kurzarbeit ja okay dann wird halt so und
es wird ja für die diese fahrzeuge haben
ja ist damit ihnen da hat man nicht so
viel dreck reagiert das ist ein tolles
zeigt dass es funktioniert also and
karbonisierung geht in vielen oder
entlüftung von sachen geht in vielen
bereichen aber jetzt muss es eben
importiert werden sagt das ministerium
auch dann können wir ja importe machen
damit zerstören wir die eigene
mittelständische industrie das geht
nicht aus meiner sicht wir werden
überall abhängig von importen wir sollen
weil bei solar seine zwölf große hurra
rufe aus schreien aber wenn mir batterie
und solar zusammenrechnen die ganzen
stoffe die wir da brauchen und verbauen
müssen kriegen wir aus china china also
zwischen lupenreine demokratie und gegen
putins russland dadurch zu vergleichen
was sind das von affentheater es ist
alles anrüchig also ich glaube eher dass
dass wir auch in rohmers besichtigen
können zurzeit in den letzten jahren
jahrzehnten insbesondere der
regierungszeit von frau merkel ist uns
ja quasi eingeredet worden und wir haben
alle mehr oder weniger billigen kauf
genommen dass allen fragen der
wirtschaft und der zukunft nur im
zusammenspiel aller länder gelöst werden
können also man kann im grunde nur noch
im großen verbund alles lösen das war ja
das großem andrang und das ist wenn die
sonne scheint echt hübsch verabredet mit
dem irgendwas schönes der hält sich dran
und dann verabredet man mit dem was
schönes am besten verabreden die sich
auch alle noch untereinander und am
schluss sind alle glücklich das ist so
richtig schön ist es kuschel bällebad
dass wir uns das vorgestellt haben aber
dieses dieses system übersteht den
stresstest jetzt nicht weil es nämlich
besser wäre man könnte sachen selber
also die bizarrste sache ist ja die
glasherstellung wo wir also sozusagen
aus ideologischen gründen gegen fracking
sind und uns das zeug dann aus kanada
oder irgend woher herr liefern lassen
also die können es machen wir machen es
nicht da würde ich doch mal sagen wenn
wir da und zwar in die moderne form des
frackings investiert hätten oder würden
dann hätten wir etwas was erst einmal
und in dem moment wo ich es ausspreche
sitzen da draußen menschen und sagen na
ja das ist aber ein sehr rationaler ein
sehr nationaler zugang zu allen genau
weil wenn man sich nämlich für sich
selber sagt dann ist man den krisen
nicht von anderen abhängig und wenn man
zu viel von anderen abhängig ist dann
geht es ein kleines leck ein punkt also
ich glaube tatsächlich auch unsere
mentalität muss sich ändern das kann
nicht sein dass wir sagen wir wollen
warum wollt fracking gas wir wollen
fracking gas aus den usa aber machen die
hände nicht schmutzig da glaub wir
nehmen atomenergie freunden das winkel
und weniger werbung zu schalten hier
eine
normalisierung zwar genau deswegen da
will ich einmal massiv widersprechen
natürlich muss man gucken dass man sich
nicht von einem land abhängig mache und
das sicherlich mit blick auf russland
sehr viel falsch gelaufen aber gerade
die deutsche wirtschaft profitiert doch
massiv davon dass sie in viele länder
investieren kann und in viele länder
ihre produkte verkaufen kann
vielleicht haben auch zugehört wie die
gerade die deutschen autobauer viele
mittelständler die dran denn die
profitieren noch massiv davon dass die
produkte in den usa und vor allem in
china verkauft werden können wenn wir
jetzt sagen wir wickeln das alles ab und
jedes land soll nur noch produkte
herstellen dies in ihrem eigenen hat ja
haben sollte ich bin neu aber sie haben
einen massiven wohlstands
worauf wir nur viel stärker achten
müssen in zukunft und das ist die lehre
aus der aktuellen situation dass wir uns
breiter aufstellen und uns nicht von
einem land so abhängig machen wie das in
energie bereich von russland hat
vielleicht kann ich vielleicht kann sie
haben durchaus den richtigen gedanken
aber genau genommen ist das was wir seit
jahrzehnten machen und im grunde müssten
heute an den euro diskutieren weil dem
grund übel bei der ganzen angelegenheit
ist viel zu langer zeit genau genommen
sind wir sehr wahllos gewesen in der
wahl unserer partner denn das thema
china dass er seit den neunziger jahren
eine große rolle spielt wo ganz viele
deutsche firmen in der hoffnung auf
billige arbeitskräfte und große menschen
ihre arbeitsplätze hin verlagert haben
aber eben nicht nur ihre arbeitsplätze
sondern vor allen dingen das know how
das die chinesen gerne genommen haben um
es dann zu kopieren aus chinesischer
sich genau das richtige hat er dazu
geführt dass wir uns schritt für schritt
unsere eigene unabhängigkeit die wir
gehabt haben beraubt haben noch dazu
kommt dass wir uns als eu gegen china
und abschotten müssen damit china nicht
mit der billigkonkurrenz den
europäischen markt kaputt macht die sind
im grunde steht hinter der der
russlandkrise also sie basieren die
nächste schon längst an dass das thema
china und china als vormachtstellung in
1 teilen der welt könnte längst erkannt
werden und wir reden immer davon dass
wir sie nicht kritisch gegenüberstehen
dürften ja wir müssen eine schließt das
andere nicht aus das ist eine schwierige
und stuben wir sind jetzt aber wollen
wir gar nicht mehr dass in china das
gibt dann tatsächlich glaube ich das
werden wir jetzt als freie welt uns von
diktaturen unabhängiger machen wollen es
geht nie um alles oder nichts aber
unabhängige dann brauchen wir mit china
zum beispiel eine strategie der
verhandlung auf augenhöhe und so hat er
sowieso wie ich so wie china ganz klare
regeln für investitionen im ausland
stellt und damit seine eigene format
position in den unternehmen sicherheit
hätte europa das auch machen können ist
aber am ende nicht passiert so haben wir
am ende noch hingegeben und es gibt ganz
viele autos
sie haben wir letzte tötet und seo
logischen gründen es gibt ganz viele
beispiele das heißt wir könnten oder
müssen aus den fehlern mit russland und
china lernen aber wir
schreiben ein leider wir starten gerade
wie das kaninchen auf die schlange auf
das schlage auf das russland problemen
und seen ganzes ist china problem wir
bleiben einmal beim russland problemen
bei der frau hermenau plädieren sie ja
eigentlich für etwas pragmatismus